this is first in a series of meetings as
we prepare to get ready an integer
release of Wolfram language version 12
and the thing we're doing is to look at
functions that have been tagged as
experimental in previous versions and
see which things we believe we can
commit long-term to and what might need
design changes so first up in our list
for today is our anatomy related
functions so Anatomy plot 3d and its
friends so let's take a look at this the
question is
are we confident of the way this is
working I have to say I don't think I've
had any objections to this for a while
um
the plot themes are were a nice addition
we add those most recently and
everything seemed to work just fine when
we added those so right but I mean the
question really in terms of usage here
let's sum I mean so we've got I my
tendency is to say that this is fine
ready to go um I have not really had any
problems with it um we haven't really
gotten any negative feedback or anything
like that I think in general people
liked it in fact they were kind of
surprised when they saw it some right
yeah I don't think it's changed and why
is it wiggling so much when I when I try
and rotate it that's basically it's a
graphics 3d with a box where the box is
turned off so you're not seeing the
corners of the box but then when you let
go it snaps to that's the default
behavior of the front-end for graphics
3d what do you mean I mean what but but
the fact that there's a hidden box I
don't understand why we're snapping
anything I mean this shouldn't snap it's
nothing special you know I understand
that but I'm saying that for this
application given that I see so if I say
boxed to true then I should see the Box
correct let me ask you another question
about the coordinate system for this
thing mm-hmm
so if I say what is the coordinate
system is it in millimeters of unified
human measurement system it's basically
on the bottom of the foot it's in what
in millimeters form the bottom of the
foot vertical up standing okay that's
basically plus/minus on the two sides of
the body
correct okay well at least it's obvious
which way is in front I suppose um what
is this the region bounds
so if I say something like if I say here
something like plot range arrow left
foot and I say something like I don't
even know if I do it well no I'm saying
third metatarsal is that a bone yes it
is a bone so what's this going to look
like I see so that and what happens if I
want to make the left foot in some other
styles so I can if I say here can I say
style left foot and then can I say
opacity 0.3 for example what did I do
wrong
closing curly that's cool did it work
I mean did that metatarsal gatim well
the metatarsal is part of that foot so
it may have picked up the opacity from
but it shouldn't have done that would be
a bug yeah I mean do I have to put an
explicit style here
I don't think that's them I figure we
can try we can try looking into that the
style directive is a bit weird because I
know in general the front ends mainly
what pays attention to that but we can
definitely look into see enough styles
misbehaving here if it's doing alright
what the rest of the graphics 3d system
doesn't do we believe in the function in
this thing called skin stall because the
words skin could have a bunch of other
meanings in computational geometry and
so on do we do we really believe that
we're going to you know that the woods
skin is okay to use here in the context
of this function that's not a question
obviously but we're we have a general
thing called skin style right which is a
little bit weird to me be faced I would
think so but then it's rather strange to
call it anatomical skin style I mean
right in the context of this it looks
just fine I'm not as convinced as I
might be here and I don't know I mean
Felix's asking was know someone is
asking um if somebody's asking wasn't
flippered somebody else asking um you
know how many users are there for an
area like this it's very hard to know I
mean you know we run into people who use
it but it's kind of anecdotal we that's
the feature of you know high privacy
kind of you know prepackaged software
if someone is asking how often the
anatomy data packet is requested that's
a good question that we probably do know
I don't think we've looked at it have we
we have but they don't know event okay
um and and again that can all be messed
up because there might be one example
that a bunch of people have seen that
would you know one example for high
school kids or something that happens to
include this that would cause a large
number of downloads all right let's go
back to the design question here um the
we could use something like epidermis
instead of skin well which would at
least make it more specific right and is
it in fact the epidermis or is it I mean
who knows I don't know how many
different layers of the skin there are I
mean is you have to get into careful and
Anatomy contextual issues like is
epidermis really the whole thing we're
calling skin but right alright let's go
back and look a little bit more an
Anatomy 3d okay so we've got an anime 3d
we've also got um Anatomy form
which is a derivative
why is that different from style form is
there a style form well I just I'm sorry
its style rather that's what I used here
but what one issue is that Anatomy form
allows you to given an association to
tag individual sub structures within the
larger entity so for example in that
first example you're asking for the left
arm but you're saying I want the sub
part which is the biceps brachii to be
green and style doesn't I'm pretty sure
Brett can verify this uh does not accept
associations or anything like no no no
it does not but but is it even possible
to use style in anatomy plot 3d I've
seen it work in certain cases yes I tend
to put explicit directives but what are
we going to do
when we finally have the the female
anatomy stuff ready how are we going to
specify that I believe that's going to
be done through the entity reference in
other words it will almost be like an
annotated I'm not an annotation or
qualifier on the entity itself by
default if you're saying you do ctrl
equal left foot and it gives you an
assuming on that would be correct I
don't think there would be anything in
the function itself anatomy plot 3d that
would necessarily indicate what you know
because you know model you know similar
to a Geo model for Geographics I agree
so an option well and also I have
another question since we're getting
insane no not the cats and dogs and cows
and horses and so on what are we gonna
do with those they can all work through
the same function or are they gonna have
to have their own sets of functions what
is the status so Michael I mean like
like we have those skeletons and things
right we are in Deportes I would say
okay but so the idea I agree with with
was a Brett who's saying that they you
know we need an Anatomy model like geo
model just seemed sensible so but there
are
in terms of the the naming of these
different pieces
I mean horses have fema's don't they I
mean any of the there is a
correspondence right that was long
studied by the naturalist or whatever
these correspondences between different
body parts for different you know
creatures keh keh cocaine but so are
there so tell me I mean various animals
have bones that humans don't have right
okay so sorry I didn't hear if you were
fundamentally humans don't have tails
right um
okay so and and there are multiple bones
and there multiple bones in a dog tail
yeah that's right so okay so but in the
case where okay but by the way do we
actually have that data can we look at
that in the prototype build yet the dog
okay okay but any case so Anatomy plot
3d is clearly going to work for dogs as
well so how is this going to look so
it's gonna say something like so this
anatomical structure entity is going to
be distinguished or not for dog versus
human presumably that's going to be a
different entity for the dog
that would be my expectation yes I mean
they don't see how that's gonna work so
why so look here's the problem that
we've got
in the case of geo position right if we
say geo you know look if if we do like
you know Apollo 11 landing site right
that is going to give us a result which
is a geo position with gym you know with
moon as the entity right
we don't have an analogous so whereas
let's see if we say I mean clearly there
is no homologous Eiffel Tower on the
moon at least this is so like North Pole
yeah good question that's a good
question right North Pole which for us
maps into what oh don't tell me doesn't
matter okay that is a named geo position
right on the earth now it's really it's
not tied to any geo model
right but here should work on the moon
or Venus or well the way this works is
that the geomod adoption has default
automatic so what it does is that it
goes first into the first argument of
Geographics and it sees whether there is
a model there and if there is a model
then we will take that one so if I say
so for example if I do this if I say geo
list plot let's take these two if I say
J let's plot of that um this thing here
right which is on the moon and then I
say comma this guy here which is the
North Pole is this going to do the right
thing or is this gonna do the wrong
thing it should be on the moon cool
why doesn't it have a second oh it does
have a second dot there wow that's
pretty cool I wonder what projection
it's using does it have any idea I mean
does it what projection is that using I
think it's DC Circuit Agra you know it's
my guess but on the earth the
corresponding thing so that's near the
equator of the moon right am i right No
yes okay um so if I did the same thing
on the earth would I get the same I mean
so in other words if I take cheerless
plot let's just take out that geo
position wherever it is on the earth the
homologous geo position on the earth so
to speak comma the thing on the moon I
mean sorry to come at the North Pole
then close off the first year position
aha okay so it looks like it's the same
projection yes okay and I guess it's a
correct angle R because medicator would
send the pole to infinity so if we see
the pole oh oh I see so but if I were to
make that something if I were to make
that eighty nine point five twenty five
it's still quite large so I Mercator is
selected when the size is relatively
small like less than two thousand
kilometers
okay what's that projection there that's
now lumber Lucinda which is the one we
use for intermediate scales but why I
mean since that obviously can represent
the pole why is that not what it's doing
in this case here because that's good
because it reaches the pole it jumps to
that larger case so for for the largest
with situations it chooses so somewhere
in the middle of this the automatic
heuristic is going to flip over right
okay
I mean you think that's right basically
yes all these things can be fine-tuned a
bit but somewhere right I have some
numbers like two thousand kilometers and
eight thousand kilometers and all they
scaled for the planet toys yes yes this
is all scaled yes by the way why isn't
that a desert why is there something
green there good question there must be
something various questions on the live
stream here most recent is why why not
have starting and braces colored
actually they are if I make them on
unmatch they will get covered and
they're actually we're coming soon is a
whole ghosting mechanism for for making
it easier to match things so he's asking
if dog plot the 3d is coming
[Music]
well okay okay all right let's go back
to this question so I'm not happy with
the answer here so so the issue with the
there's a conflict here because on the
one hand we've got an entity that is you
know a generic a female for example we
don't have a notion of a generic species
like the poverties attached on the
theory form a human for every die fine
when the properties are defined what it
entity is no I understand that so you're
saying but the point that I'm making is
in so you're saying in the future if I
say fimo it's gonna give an assuming
which says assuming a human male fimo uh
you know use a female dog femur instead
it's the only realistic way I see just
concerns of people okay can we
externally influence that assumption
I mean programmatically so like if we do
have an Anatomy model goes to female dog
you know is there no way I mean to
influence the the the stack that does
the NLU not a chance
okay very hard I mean when we give it
back right now as the assuming and 34 we
can pick it out buttock science that I
mean
colonel doesn't get access to the
assuming is currently right actually it
has an environment when when you call it
from inside but but but it's too late
right I may already know it gets all
baked and it decides which one to take
no but but Michael if you're typing and
you haven't even decided okay so I'm
typing Anatomy plot 3d and I know I'm
thinking about a dog there's nothing we
can do as you know as you mean you have
said certain power meters before what
what parameters would I have to have set
them and how would I actually type this
yet options are not to be broadly dd4
animal goes to or give or take mm-hmm
and then kind of magically influence the
yeah because it couldn't take sensitive
control we have that but that's a very
obscure way to do it to do some set
options to achieve it look I mean the
other possibility is we've got this
Anatomy form wrapper oh gosh no no this
cannot do it they said that must be
totally independent from the entity okay
what is anatomy form doing so Anatomy
form is allowing us to differently style
different elements of an anatomical
structure right we're different classes
of elements for example instead of the
biceps brachii you could say control
equal muscle or is that here listen stop
load that here this is not a very useful
thing here um right
so yeah we need an example so we should
change that to show that case you think
but but because that is clearly useful
case I mean let's look for example let's
do that for the foot ok just so we
understand what it's doing um so we've
got here um and by the way oh boy I mean
we've got to have the plot range but the
same thing is true with Geo plots and
people don't have too much trouble with
that but the plot range hmm I'm thinking
you know obviously you can't say left
foot of a human you get in a crazy
situation if you're defining the
coordinate system the coordinate range
from the left foot of a human and you've
actually got a dog foot in the in the
thing you're looking at did that make
any sense I didn't understand that well
here let me just try typing that what I
was going to do here so Anatomy form
there so what am I doing here I'm saying
control equal bone goes to green okay
oops no bone
okay so bone is an anatomical structure
goes and then that's that and then what
am i doing here I'm doing that's the
anatomy form and why is that not working
like style where as a wrapper what can I
do that as a wrapper
it's like face form which I which okay
but that's a directive right so this is
my foot a foot with the bones green
it's that correct mm-hm except it's not
doing it for some reason it's thinking
harder and it's possibly having to get
it you know individualized data instead
of all coming in is you know one default
styled that's a question for the caching
infrastructure does anybody know whether
that weather Anatomy data has the
correct caching hierarchy does have a
good layout for it but a lot of I mean
the way that the caching work
is that the majority of these graphics
CDs are stored separately from the
normal data repository so it sometimes
takes additional time to fetch them but
what do you think it did in this case
did it fetch every bone separately well
I'm gonna take a quick look and see I
don't know how Anatomy form
fundamentally informs the graphics 3d if
it's telling it to fetch all I'd have to
look it's been a while since I've looked
into it could you guys look and see
whether we can reset the caching you
know because it probably should whatever
the hierarchy is that is quick to I mean
the basic rule is if it's quick to
specify it should be in a bucket to be
loaded together in other words if I were
going to label every bone separately
with a different color well all bets are
off you can pick those up separately but
if it's a single thing that I'm labeling
I should be able to get that whole you
know collection of objects that
represent the bones together well I
would I will say that I know for a fact
that when we collect the information as
to what bones are in it that should
definitely be making a single entity
value called the only part that might
not be batched as you might say would be
the part where it downloads the models
because there you're essentially
importing models from a CDN server okay
and that you can't really there's not if
I don't think import is really hooked up
to any kind of a caching mechanism okay
I think that's the thing to look up for
Nick it really it comes from the CDN so
that the thing this is not coming from
the entity correct the models themselves
do yeah the end the models themselves do
not come down through the entity value
call basically just a bunch of URLs come
down that says what their CDN location
is and then we do an import on those
okay and those models will be cache on
the client side but it takes it's a
little more work to pull them down and
because of the the size associated with
them they're not we don't have a super
diverse subset of the graphics in the
pre cache blocks but I'll take a look
well maybe maybe we should expand that
but okay let's let's zoom out again for
a second here so first point is I don't
understand
so anatomy form Michael Hale is pointing
out it's like geo styling and I think
that's correct right it's a directive in
the same way that geo styling is a
Directorate
is that true
you know I think what contagious so why
is it called anatomy form rather than
anatomy styling given that the form
concept I guess we thought of this as an
extension to the graphics 3d language in
to us it was more like face form yeah I
understand whereas geo styling is more
of a I mean these are all directives and
what is the analogous so if I say style
of blah , anatomy form is that going to
work as a rapper so like for example if
I take this case and I say here style is
this gonna work my understanding is that
the second argument of style has to be
something the front end understands have
to be ok
I mean it just means that you have to
process it end of the day right so this
I think I hope yeah that works fine
that's all the way the default viewpoint
for these things is what from the front
but that's not the front of a foot that
is well but it is that it's the front of
the body I don't believe you I'm sorry I
said I don't believe you look at that
foot yeah because the front the feet
aren't point the toes aren't pointed
straight ahead they're actually slightly
outwards oh oh I see but that's a left
foot yep okay let's look at the two feet
together okay I thought this was going
to be a super easy
I predict that we're not going to end up
the experimental eyes in this stuff this
particular section yet because I think
with the particularly the homologous
structures and other critters and so on
um are still complicated and the
male/female things looks complicated to
me too okay what's happening here why is
this not coming back quickly
the Sun suddenly slowed down because the
left foot on its own came back perfectly
quickly
okay well I thought that was like bad
for my thought is bad for your hips to
have your feet pointed out like that who
knows what do I know is that really the
sort of the lowest energy configuration
so to speak of the human yes it depends
on how healthy you are I know my arches
are high so actually my feet would also
be tilted up who knows all right but but
okay so okay so first point is so the
style thing worked as expected is it
documented please check that it's
documented is okay so let's let's loop
back to the different animals versus
male-female okay so what we imagine so
are we going to replicate for the
male-female models do we imagine we have
the male female you know male left femur
and the female left female is that the
idea I mean most of the bones in our
particular models actually don't differ
CACO you must say what's actually I
talked to the model provider last year
and he basically mentioned that he not
to have different female male versus
female he only thinking about adding
pelvic differently yeah that's what I
thought but and but those have to be you
know obviously there's the you know
there's there's some some intermediate
bone somewhere that has to interpolate
between the okay the basic point is
you're saying it so happens that okay I
don't know what - anatomist say if you
hand them a this must be a well known
thing you know you hand them a random
femur can they say if it's male or
female must be known to archaeologists
if nobody else I mean certainly for the
whole skeleton it's rather easy but but
if you just give a single peripheral
bone so to speak
like a forensic scientist finds a body
can you find a femur and determine if it
came from a male or a female yeah that
would be the question so I don't think
anyway I believe they can that's how
they figure out if there's it's a female
mummy or male female mummy or whatever
well but look if they come all the bones
your hand too but right but do they know
that bones they use okay but that if
it's pelvic bones then it's easy right
so the UM okay but the question then
remains for us if we have an entity that
is left femur if in fact we end up with
two identical entities for male and
female left femur that's kind of stupid
right so how are we going to do this
Keiko does umls differ between the male
and the female anatomy don't distinguish
male and female females so they only
distinguish the structures that have
obvious differences pelvis reproductive
organs they have a specific female male
like okay yes fine but but okay but for
example take pelvis for instance right
which is clearly different right today
how do they name those so they actually
call it a male cobras and female promise
okay Wow okay so that what that is
suggesting to me I mean let me know
sorceress as you're my less evolved in
this respect or has Yama has always been
this way it looks like this way okay so
then a reasonable approach for us would
be that most bones most organs will not
disambiguate and they'll just be generic
but some will yeah that's right okay so
given that that's the case
if you ask boy this is complicated I
mean when we have a so everything in the
hierarchy above that includes a pelvis
for example has to do as to disambiguate
right you know that's right it starts
from our female human body and makes
human body okay okay so okay so I think
we're coming back to Michael's claim
that it all has to be disambiguated at
the entity level which sounds like the
only possible thing would you suggest
that the Anatomy model thing is not
going to work for this neither does a
male female sort of thing what do we can
do for dog bones presumably there we
simply have to do a disambiguation if
you type in left femur it's going to say
assuming human just like it does for
genomics assuming human since that is
our market so to speak um and you know
you can pick dog instead that correct
that sounds correct to me yeah that
sounds reasonable
I mean because the other thing that I
was thinking I was thinking a moment ago
that was problematic for Anatomy model
is what if you wanted to do an overlay
of you know male versus female pelvis
you know so you could sort of see what
the difference between them was well you
can you just put a list of two entities
and when you ask for but if we you know
if we had gone to the Anatomy model
route and versus female human right the
analogous question of you know where a
Paris and London on the moon is
surprisingly hard to answer that is you
know we you know and we certainly
haven't missed status you right in other
words the making the geo positions
correspond you have to go in and change
the geo models by hand which is
perfectly reasonable because that's a
very weird operation in this case each
one has a coordinate system so
presumably a dog has a coordinate system
analogous to this whatever it is um an
HS or something is that correct what is
the coordinate system for the dog so
basically I aligned to human it must be
scaled based on the links of the female
okay
so and what kind of dog did you pick
also it's just general model it's not
specific but I mean there I'm not a big
dog expert but between Chihuahuas and
Sybilla nerds there's a distinct
difference in scale yeah that's right so
it's just general so it's like a few
feet so I mean it's like a couple of
like three feet taller so I mean what I
mean sorry humor waist okay okay
and and we picked that because there is
some generic standard you know average
dog
yeah okay um okay somebody is telling
actually this is useful some things on
the live stream here bones can tell you
sex skeletons overall size can give some
clues within same population males tend
our larger more robust bones blah blah
blah um right the skull size features
that can indicate sex okay though less
reliably hmm actually I think I did know
that for a very terrible reason which
I'm not going to explain um
that I learned on a visit to Cambodia um
in the case
the
okay age also differentiates bones
because they grow at different rates
that is another can of worms guys that's
another kind of worms we have an adult
skeleton right
yes but do we have any concept of
allometric growth stuff that would let
us map to a different because we have
you know human growth data right so we
know and that even gives us relative
head size and other things doesn't it
I don't sing at a scale precise enough
to be scared of ethics okay even though
it is ultimately there is essentially a
growth field that determines I mean you
know it's a fairly coarse thing that
determines the relative size relative
growth rates of different parts we don't
test us we don't have the data well
maybe you're saying we don't have the
data or you think it's a hopeless no I
don't have the ability of course field
data no I understand that but that stuff
is somewhat known I mean that's the
whole allama tree business right yeah
but were we to have it I'm not saying we
have it now but I'm just trying to
understand as we to do the design for
the future were we to have the growth
field data then is there a chance that
we could actually map it for different
ages
I would use it with your pretty stranger
is it always as simple as just scaling
it because like for example I know that
like in a baby's skull that actually our
friend Gautham does scooped her at
Colombia is an expert on on this whole
issue and we could easily ask him he'll
probably tell us that it's way too
complicated or he'll tell us that he's
already got models for it it might be
worth at least asking um okay let's take
a look at other comments on the
livestream actually um dogs have a wide
variety of skeletons really you mean
their relative size of their bones are
different um how do you deal with
animals that have different shapes
during their lifetime such as
butterflies oh we have not you know
we've got okay we've got a long way to
go before we reach butterflies and but
you know if we have to so just to
understand just for a second the human
age thing that would presumably be
handled in the same way that we're using
dated for other entities
it's that correct I mean what we would
expect to do were we to ever be able to
support this but the data is deducted
Kruger for a qualifier I understand for
an entity qualifier poverty I see but I
can still do if I say something like
dated France 1930 or something right
can't I use that as does that work or is
that not going to work yes
so I can say entity value can I do it
with the sub value form yes okay so
that's gonna give me the population of
France in 1930 but it is kinda in some
sense chuckle right but were we to want
to do this parameterize you know humans
we could say dated of fimo such-and-such
or something analogous to that yeah okay
look I think we've still got some
problems here so let's let's walk back
through this so first I don't think
there's a huge rush 2d experimental eyes
this Anatomy stuff and I would recommend
that we don't do it right now but I
think we need to solve this at least the
male-female thing and at least some of
the Somali coast bones they comments I
don't think there's anything special
with respect to are not to be put any
entity where you call with this problem
whatever that when you ask for example
female animal there's nothing really
special to Anatomy plot I feel fair
enough but okay look my other objections
here our skin style I hate I think it's
way too generic a name vacate I really
think we need to fix that but wasn't
earth are we going to call it and why
are we specifically identifying the skin
as because it was a convenience thing I
mean you could have asked for that part
in the list of in the first argument you
could have just said hey give me the
skin of the left femur and it would have
you know included it that way and you
could use you know your own stuff this
was considered to be kind of a
convenience for I want to see where this
is in context to the skin and allow you
some convenient ways to style it well on
there it's mostly coming from the eyes
of the presentation where we always show
anything with respect to the whole body
and because we here we don't have
anymore it could be
rather than through the whole body
anymore I see so this is kind of like
gridlines in the video I mean so Michael
isn't it also the case that if you were
in the anatomy plot 3d and you said left
foot and control equals skin is the two
things that you wanted to include that
the skin is all of the skin and so you'd
suddenly get the entire body yes the
skin is all of this kid but we do have
support yeah we do have entities it's
just this is complete right finding it
for you but this skin is the whole skin
yes right so this would have to say left
you know skin is this is this only the
skin that is near that bone or what
correct we have a property that
basically tells us for each entity of
what the nearest skin part is so we're
able to grab that conveniently but but
wait a minute these skin parts are
separately segmented pieces of skin is
that right correct yes we manually cut
the whole body skin into moments and
what are they cooled well scale the left
hand skin at the right hand scandal but
this isn't this is not a complete lake
right this is only the top I see okay
did we did make him up there again from
your LMS okay um okay but so this this
skin style thing is is very much like
anatomy form or no it isn't isn't like I
think what you say it's more likely good
line to show you show you some local
reference for him yes I understand
hmm and is it the
such I mean if you are having an
internal organ like a well the pituitary
gland you had here yeah okay that's
pretty weird wouldn't earth it's this
weird mosque like thing it's it's
because there's a hole for the back of
the neck and so the opacity is making it
look a little weird the whole thing is
blue and transparent but because the top
part what is it I mean why is that
that's the scan of the head that's a
hole at the bottom and in the back of
the skin of the head okay I need to
understand oh my gosh this particular
section is going to be easy why is this
so slow as well this is crazy
he needs a pretty big object what the
skin is a pretty big object oh wow so
this is where that is totally confusing
so there are several points that are
confusing here so okay so I get well
it's that with aperture Atika why is
this rotating with the Patricia kind
staying fixed is this rotating around
the pituitary gland no well why is the
it's rotating around the center of the
graphic just it's a the baby six 3d so
okay so it so happens that the Patricia
gland is in the center approximately so
this very approximately right but this
is looks totally bizarre I mean I don't
think we have any choice but what again
what is determining the default
viewpoint what yeah it's literally view
point goes to front which is just a
graphics treated option all right okay
fine but then why is the neck I don't
understand what was that it's a fact
it's a diagonal slice because the neck
is a boy this is pretty confusing yeah
okay all right fine um we could use it
explicitly specified viewpoint in this
example to be from the font right then
becomes obvious well fine I think
to do that this example is very bizarre
I mean it's you know it looks like some
kind of weird Batman costume type thing
um okay
he'll be in the New Avengers infinity
war movie um okay let's go back here
okay so this question about skin style
and what it should be called I mean we
certainly thought about this when we
first when we last named it so to speak
I'm not happy about this name though
because I just think it's going to end
up being unless we think that the name
is usable for other meanings of the word
skin and do we have anybody here from
the computational geometry team no I
don't think so you're thinking this
might be something used in conjunction
with textures or something maybe in a
general sense well if it was useful
there I don't know that it would
necessarily be a horrible overlap well
we should figure that out the other
possibility or another possibility
although it also strikes me as weird is
that we could use boundary style for
this the boundary of the human that's
pretty weird
all right listen bottom line here we are
closer to being able to do experimental
eyes these things and maybe we'll get
them in this cycle but let's move on in
this meeting because we've got a lot of
other stuff to cover people in the
meeting or do you want us to drop out or
I think you can drop out but let's let's
I mean the main thing here is is skin
style the right name we got to talk to a
computational geometry folk and I think
we've more or less resolved the whole
question about dogs and other entities
but I would like to just check that and
work through it and just see some
samples of how that works
yeah yep okay let's move on
completely different topic here the next
next topic on our list would be okay so
the anatomy folk can drop if they want
to so next on our list is blockchain
functionality
[Music]
so again I'm not I am not convinced that
we're going to be able to do
experimental eyes yet on this and here's
why I think we're okay in terms of I
mean first of all our representation of
blockchain transaction data seems to me
to be not quite there yet but first of
all how do we feel about the blockchain
based business I think we're going to
need you know when we say aetherium here
that means the etherium main chain right
sorry do you actually have the
blockchain folk here oh yeah we are here
wait um okay so that's the main chain of
aetherium correct right and I have a
feeling you know it seems like in the in
this world people are talking about main
net and so on more more and more to
distinguish the the main etherium
network from other ones am i right
well at the end we're going to have both
the cerium public net and also a test
net so that people can test their stuff
before putting it in and they can and
you know one expand spending either
right
actually right now right now it works if
you did it like EP h dot main there's
also ballad option value for launching
base and how do we know what the
possible block trains are it's
documented in the blockchain base read
page okay so we can catch something like
that for the destiny this will say for a
bit going and other block chains so you
would call that a theorem test not
well that's to be decided yet we have to
look at what's a name that actually
rolled people use okay but I mean
ultimately these bases for okay next
question when we do given it's aetherium
if we had authentication could we
connect to any Imperium Network
not sure what you mean to any ethereal
Network so okay let's take of a Bitcoin
net okay if we stand up our own Bitcoin
network and it has a particular URL how
is the satchel connection made is my
question it's it's the some port number
going to some machine that has in this
case in the theory and blockchain are
correct by beacon Network you mean
having our own note or worth or making a
different lodging base in Bitcoin making
a different blockchain let's take a
theorem as an example it's running more
more realistic in modern times so like
for example our test net how is that is
that ultimately a URL for the basis for
for for a peer of that Testament a node
of that test net
I'm asking this but I mean clearly this
is a distributed thing so what we're
actually doing under the hood is we're
going to a particular node or a
particular collection of nodes right and
those nodes have URLs don't they
or they have IP addresses at least they
have IP addresses at least okay but so
once you get there they have an IP
address and a port number is that a true
statement
that's right and then they need to know
once you're on that port what protocol
are you talking on that port is that
correct
that's correct and for etherium is there
a single protocol or are there multiple
possible protocols to talk we denote
there is a single protocol yes okay all
right so so ultimately I mean for our
technology stack here is it the case
that if somebody had a private aetherium
blockchain that they would simply have
to specify the IP address of a node of
their private etherion block chain
together with certain authentication
information to be able to take our
symbolic representations stuff and just
point it at their private blockchain is
that true or is that not true I think
that's true I was thinking we do have
another option to support to define the
address of the server or the node like
geoserver in the Euro attics mm-hmm well
geoserver is not my favorite we don't
have a dollar to yourself we just have a
Joseph I mean that is not my favorite
option that is definitely an escape
valve option
right yeah it's reasonable though I mean
but but um we don't have a Geo base
because in this case we're doing
something I mean this is analogous to
cloud base I would have thought we
should be able to combine these here
um
somebody's asking on the livestream the
test night wouldn't be an ode we just
mark the note actually no a test net
would be could be a multi node test net
that I mean all of these networks have a
bunch of peer-to-peer nodes on them okay
so look I suspect the right thing to do
is to somehow combine in blockchain base
to somehow combine the protocol
specification with the actual raw IP
address
um
okay let's let
to the let's zoom out for a second so
that's my first comment here is I think
we need to think more carefully about
exactly how I mean these particular ones
are probably okay they can always be
grandfathered in um but we obviously
should be generalizing this going
forward
um
let's see
how are we here okay so once we get into
a blockchain block data um I again I'm
I'm skeptical that we're going to be
able to do experimental eyes yet okay
are we happy with are we happy with all
of these names here I mean we have been
through them several times yeah but
since for version 12 we expect to add
more stuff to that and so the current
design I think is fine but we should
think about an ER design for all the
other extra information will provide
like what ok very naive question why is
the nonce the nonce is just an integer
right so it's not given in and it's not
a hex hash yeah that's right I'm sorry
I'm answering my own question that ok go
ahead what were you gonna say yeah I was
talking more about blockchain
transaction data yup so in that case so
there are subfields of the inputs and
outputs we think are useful to provide I
agree this is largely incomprehensible
right now right maybe since you're also
planning to include probably at least a
bunch more of different block chains
probably then we'll have a better view
of what would be the names for for all
of these right but I mean specifically
here ok so this address there's nothing
I can do with this address right now is
that correct you can because if that
address points to the previous output
the output that is linked to this input
here so you know where the where the
money came from but we also want to
include some additional values there
also to go back to the two other to the
previous output no other thing if I want
to search the blockchain for mentions of
this address we have no way to do that
right now is that correct
we have no blockchain search function
yet nope and this address I mean the
fact that these are undecorated hex
strings rather than something with some
symbolic wrapper is a little odd um I
mean how should I think about that
address
what what what is that what is the full
description of that address is that you
know given this particular blockchain
this is an address of somebody who
accessed that blockchain if I'm not
mistaken so the database is again linked
either is used in the output that if you
see well to pick up another transaction
see if it had some other stuff in it
yeah I'm also not thrilled with the fact
that the transactions have different
things in them each time
rather than okay so what's this one that
one is
does this mean can you on can you
interpret this for me yeah what is the
number
go ahead but your can you go to Bitcoin
Tina said yeah it's easier to explain in
Bitcoin this
you
okay should I go further back in the in
the blockchain from the most recently
mind block or does it not matter in
Scent matter yes done get the first
transaction because the first
transaction is the coinbase transaction
so get another one
bla bla bla bla bla so what happens if
you mind the blocks only every ten
minutes okay
all right right if you see the input
there you see there's a source foreign
section right yup
so that's her transaction if you go to
actually you can do a blockchain
transaction data of that transaction and
you'll see the outputs okay so in that
case if you see so we were seeing
address 1 for 12
so you see the first output of that
transaction was the input to this
transaction right so that's one one
thing we we need to add there is also
the the output index how could there be
this number of source confirmations I
don't understand that this is a recently
mind block what does that mean
let me check this
okay let's put that on the shelf for a
second my biggest complaint is about
what's in the script byte array right we
also want to provide the string form of
the I shall two things so they ideally
we want to have this scrape interpreter
right where you can where you can't have
as any input one of these scripts and it
will run the Bitcoin script in and based
on that we can also work and differ
interpreter for different block chains
is it true that that that script array
is ultimately essentially a lambda that
eats things like addresses it can be
anything because what the Bitcoin
blockchain does is you get the so you
have the the input script that is called
unlocking script and you combined it
with the output script which is called a
locking script and you combine those and
the result of executing those scripts
should be true if you want to spend the
bitcoins so you can have anything there
there are some standard scripts but
don't really but but those scripts have
arguments which are the rest of this
data on inputs some of that is arguments
to the script is that true or is this or
is this address somewhere inside the
script now and you're just showing it
outside is by confer convenience they
are not necessarily they're not
arguments for this so the the arguments
for the output script comes in the they
come from the input script where they
put all that in this stack and then the
output screen starts reading from the
stack and the the other stuff is I'm
sorry so the input script here
references this external stuff or does
not reference the external stuff or is
that in that 107 bytes will I find one
for one two
blah blah blah or not
what is this anyways this is this some
some kind of base64-encoded thing
space 58 the venom room but it's a what
is it ultimately is it a hash or is a
day what is it and if it is a hash why
isn't it a hash given in hex the way
this hash is given in hex
could be cut really what's that you make
senator public address or the person
that send the money it would be
somewhere it's that I think it is that
but but I'm asking why is that why is it
for added in base fifty-eight here
rather than in in hex why are we being
why are we not being consistent here
okay two questions why we're not that's
one that's consistent because when you
create a Bitcoin address you start with
the you start with the with a public key
and I'm from there your star apply in
different caches and at the end you you
have to apply the base 50 a check
function to get this address that's the
standard bit going okay all right fine
but this business about pushing things
on the stack you're saying that the way
this works is the input what where are
the arguments that are pushed on the
stack or does this byte array they live
there in there so probably here in the
byte array you will have a signature and
a public key so those two go to the to
the stack and then the the output script
starts doing some operations over that
so okay but so in other words in
principle everything here this is this
address redundant is what I'm trying to
understand is that data already
contained inside the script byte array
I mean this data like like the sequence
number that's metadata for this input
that is not contained within the script
byte array right yeah so that address is
not probably not in that in the industry
so sorry that we understand is it's a
lambda in the sense that it is expecting
certain arguments in order to do its job
is that true
the input scrip no it's not expecting
arguments well then how does it use the
address doesn't the address appear in
the in the operations that are being
done and the instructions that are being
done by the virtual machine
well it's related to the public key
using the Indian bit script in this case
the addresses I think I'm gonna
understand this a lot better when we
actually have the symbolic form of the
prescriptive pie - right are you getting
confused with aetherium where you
actually expect some some inputs and
over here you just you know prints
things on a ledger inputs outputs or
whatever instructions that still you can
still reverse you know you can still
decompile that script byte array into
some symbolic form that has you know
instructions they just don't happen to
be turing-complete instructions
all right right but I'm not sure if it
is expecting something I think we need
to see the the actual symbolic form of
this byte arrays before we could it's
not expecting something if you want you
I can sing you a notebook with sure why
don't you do that but um let's see some
people's people are asking things which
were interesting on the live stream
let's see is there how does the wolf and
blockchain work it is using multi chain
right um right and it is a blockchain
but it does not have mining and it does
not have a consensus algorithm right it
is just the blocks are being added by
our system based on any blocks that are
submitted or added is that correct
right we are just we are doing to mining
the results right and the question of
can one set up one's own node the answer
is we're trying to make a kit to let
people do that is that a true statement
yeah that's a word Frank you did it how
are we going on with that and we will
get this take the UM I mean for private
clouds it will be easier to do than in
the wild
is that a true statement
you're not sure okay so he's reporting
the Genesis block for Bitcoin is wrong
oh for goodness sake I mean that's
probably because we're currently getting
this from an API firm looks safer yeah
we we noticed something like that before
yes there's no need to worry we're
tracking it yes we are we in fact
solving that by I mean we're getting our
own node right right that's not
happening with our notes that bug is not
happening for our nodes
do we have our notes up and running yet
we have them running here but you didn't
have the backward to connect to those
okay fair enough
I'm and it's indeed an old book right
now okay
all right we'll look at this quickly
look at the bottom line here again sadly
is this is another thing we're not quite
ready to do experimental eyes I mean I
think we're we're circling around here
this is looking good but let's not
commit to these functions forever okay
if this notebook is coming right now we
can look at it otherwise I want to go on
to the next item here the years of it
okay I received yes so it's about
another theme but there's a section
there where I explain six you scroll
down there
script yep so whether this is is this
notebook a request for some additional
hash types yes
and is that in process that's in process
yes okay so if you scroll it down you
scroll down to the part that says login
screen and login script this year's a
brief explanation what on earth is this
so this is the D compilation of that
script is that correct right so what you
see in the login script is the the one
that comes from the output and the
unlocking script comes from the input so
what you see in the input script the
first element there is the it's a
signature and the second one is a public
key so where do I read this to a little
left to right or right to left the OP
code left to right so op dupe is doing
something to the stack
yeah it's implicating the first what is
the initial state of the stack when the
when the virtual machine is started here
in this case the the initial well the
initial is is it's just an empty stack
and when it runs this in the script you
will to do partial stack the signature
and the private and the public key so if
you scroll down I think I have a small
table there
okay so what you're basically saying oh
boy and this is the check this is the
confirmation which we're always gonna
need functions to do right there's um
there's whatever things we need yet to
run the if you see the outputs crib
you see 100 P check C function that's
something we are including the language
that has to return true for the for the
user to be able to use the bitcoins
because that's very feisty
you got the so that is an internal piece
to what is currently the decrypt
function if I'm not mistaken
the fact that this works would otherwise
this is basically determining whether
the decrypt function will give an error
I believe right so I agree that it
probably needs a I mean it needs a
general function which is yeah
interesting okay well just for once
something that is not programmatic right
now needs to be made programmatic okay
so fundamentally what you're saying is
the input script is run it puts some
stuff on the stack the output script is
then run is that right right and my
point before was said so in this case
you are seeing one of the most used
scripts I think like 90% of 95% of the
scripts are like this kind but you can
make a script that yes says I don't know
2 plus T and neither one day yeah right
um okay I mean it is something we could
I mean in the future as we get more
sophisticated computational smart
contracts will wind up with some
repositories containing these things but
okay what you're saying this is kind of
we still need to do some work here
because we've got to have it be really
clean that you can take the stuff from
this inspector of the blockchain and
just simply run it in the virtual
machine and that's not the case right
now there's a big complicated mess right
now right we you can't just take this
lump of output and say you know run in
the Bitcoin virtual machine when we have
a virtual machine function and we need
to make sure that this is designed so
that that can work right
okay let's proceed here next on our list
so that so unfortunately we're failing
to four to here not being able to do
experimental eyes these things um let's
um let's continue the next thing we have
was text translation um
which what do we know about some um
so so far as we know this is ready to go
why did it have an extra
or is that how you write it in French I
don't think it is this relates a little
bit to by the way context translation
take something with text elements as
well or can it only take a plain string
just plain text Oh text elements like
what like what you get from text
structure so if I say here
we're I to have the output of text
structure
come on Isis running so slowly for me
something is weird with this whatever
okay there we go
so this thing if I look at its input
form is a bunch of nested text elements
right right to feed that to text
translation I bet it's gonna barf
oh yeah been the same but in a perfect
world even though our text translation
system does not yet understand the
mark-up that we're giving it here in
some kind of glorious future this
you
you know one will be able to mock this
up
telling it that such and such a thing
was a noun for example and that would
help the translator
I'm just pointing out we should make
sure that this works this is easy to
flatten out actually I don't think we
have a specific function for flattening
this out is Etienne here
did I hear at here earlier yeah no we
don't something we probably should think
about right because um
okay but anyway text translation strikes
me I think okay
I'm good with this I don't have a
problem with with the experimental icing
list
anybody got any comments any objections
to that
nope okay just the fact that we might
have our own translation models in some
future and not use an API but I don't
think this change the design does not
change the design there will probably be
another value pretty metnet
option right yes would just be automatic
or something or or our own internal
version okay right good all right we got
one the experimental eyes okay let's
talk about web image search which was
the next on our list whether in search
of what's a good what are we looking at
before we were looking at some let's do
giraffes okay so I have an objection
here which I I which is this data set
that comes out this is almost never what
I want right I guess Broly usually you
thumbnails images in some case that's
correct but now the consistent thing
unfortunately web search
is doing that I use web search a lot
less often than I use web image search
mm-hmm um now with web search
what on earth will I actually end up
wanting if I were to want just a list of
things who does anybody here use web
search very much I mean I used web image
search all the time since um yeah I
guess the links are the most important
thing what is that
cool but I can just go to the April the
giraffe for example okay cool I wonder
which one is April maybe they're all
April Photoshop together um okay but so
the question here is do we break with
consistency and make web image search
returned the list of thumbnails or do we
keep consistency and then require one to
have to type in common thumbnails all
the time what the person is wet when I
use web image search I always use images
I just want the full images
that's not even a thumbnail
huh okay so my comment about nice was
that we've been talking about this
search result object to satirize all the
upwards of functions in search stop
right no you're right yes
oh boy we're not ready for this then
because if we if we bring in that thing
then we're not going to be returning
your data sent any more we're going to
be returning some kind of that web
search result that the search results
object so you're saying that that will
be analogous to text search um I need an
actual example here no I'd need this
index right so you're saying I mean this
particular thing what what is the status
of that I we talked about that a few
weeks ago right now this thing is
returning that list of content objects
right
what is this weird thing okay so that's
a search
so this is no longer correct
that documentation is wrong
and what the heck is this showing
that
result count 3 but where are they
that's really weird why did the other
one give result count three and it had
Noah no content
that is deeply suspicious to me that oh
I see look that so if I say dodo that
better not be a dodo in the Aeneid
be a dodo and Alice where is it where is
it
there is a bug here see that
Oh node you seen
the second time it shows it okay um
alright so basically you're saying that
we should be considering and I think
we're not going to do we're going to
have the display form of the search
results object be the actual search you
know the equivalent of the search engine
result page
all right we're not ready to do
experimental eyes well in research on
web search
sadly nor are we ready to the
experimental eyes Wikipedia search was
going to have the same SEO right Dulles
civics credits available not a chance
we're not the experimental izing that
that's in the middle of some whole
complicated discussion for web certain
image search I always use a max items
option so I wonder if we should make it
a third argument rather than option like
you know women surgery from nails comma
20 yes
what other
no options are recommended Scott's done
all options are documented if you want
to see all of them in the scope section
I believe except we are not linking to a
lot of other content I guess we I mean
we made the decision to make that a
little bit obscure right and so it
doesn't have its own documentation page
right is working fine fine
um okay I agree with that ends point
that I also agree that this is that it
will be useful to be able to have like
comma 20 here so long as we are still
convinced that we need this thumbnails
in which I guess from our notes point
that he sometimes wants full resolution
images that makes some sense look I
agree why don't you why don't you guys
put in max items as a third argument
allowing the option as well
yeah we can do it um
what is this so we have an example here
why is that
have an example what an earth
to show here
I was just going through some notebooks
where a head was using web search okay
is this more than entertainment value
it's mostly entertainment thank you
after the all right okay the the next
thing on our list here and we're gonna
have to wrap in a minute
is curry
do you still need a blockchain and
interested services people no I don't
think so but we're basically gonna wrap
this meeting in a minute anyway um maybe
we can just stick around for Karif
interests I'm sure my tendons and now
we've gone into some kind of the party
birds are attacking our very eyes there
we go
it's image identifying images so it's
probably the full images are maybe a
little bit too big Chris oh why are you
bothering to identify the full images
that could identify the thumbnails
perfectly well yeah but you probably get
different results than I right I doubt
it
okay well I was just for entertainment
Flip Phillips is commenting on the
service credits thing is causing trouble
for his students we know it's a mess
it's going away um somebody actually
will be useful maybe we could ask
Clayton to follow up with flip and find
out exactly what is this - is there but
we useful for us - no but we know it's a
mess um okay the okay just for one
second just for the sake of seeing if we
can can we do experimental eyes this
creature I mean I'm a little bit nervous
because I don't think it's been yet that
widely used it's yeah it's not being
used I've seen it used in mathematical
studies changed a few times but people
got it
it's meaning correct what cases did they
use to convert some functions into
operator forms right I've seen quantile
for example things in there okay so what
about these more sophisticated forms
there I mean I've seen I've seen
somebody commenting on on possible
alternatives to that but
I don't think we're ready to
experimental eyes this thing I mean I
base basic things are fine these ones
here seem complicated okay let me make a
matter comment about this meeting we got
a lot less far than I'd hoped we would
get we got kind of stuck in a in a
couple of horrible morasses there um
I am expecting I'm looking ahead at some
of the other things we have to look at I
mean the next few sections are external
programs um and this is gonna be no
there's no way yeah I see your
recommendations here are yeah the
webdriver chrome stuff and so on is
going into a different function alright
okay well look I think this some yeah
we've got lots more work to do on these
um I would like to comment that in
general the thing that we're trying to
achieve here you know even when we're
not the experimental izing we're trying
to move towards improving these
functions so that even if they don't
make it for this version to be non
experimental they can get improved for
this version and made non experimental
in a future version makes sense to
everybody then okay
well let's wrap it up here thank you to
people on the livestream quite a number
of interesting and useful comments look
forward to having you on the livestream
again soon and I think this this series
of meetings which will be on quite
diverse topics is going to continue with
some intensity over the next few weeks
thanks a lot everybody bye